watch a horse go backwards it's not very
good at that
if you can see that about a horse you
can see it about a person
for a provisional explanation we'll use
the term good to mean
a thing being fully what it is
uh that's a good blast i don't think
it's a great one
not to my taste anyway but uh it's fine
it functions
if you drilled a hole in the bottom of
it wouldn't be a good blast anymore
i was blessed with a really great
teacher and one of the best things he
understood and could explain
he knew his aristotle was how does it
come to be that we use
common nouns how can we do that
uh let's see yeah no
everything's too uniform around here
right so
pen pen right they're different how do
you know
and yet you know you can say to somebody
in another room where neither of you can
see what you're instructing the person
to do
would you please go and get me a pen on
my desk
and they got no idea what the thing's
going to look like when they get there
but they always find it this is light
work for human beings this is
automatic but and nobody ever teaches us
to do it
when we're about two years old we all
start talking
right and no other being ever does
you know we have four children we didn't
teach them to talk
they just started talking you know in
our family the children are raised just
like the dogs for the first two years
live on the floor eat the food on the
floor
you know but then they start talking
somehow they can do that and the dogs
never do
right they're still stupid that's their
charm by the way
so aristotle says that's how we see
good things are defined by their purpose
and the point is this does this
and this is a fine point right yeah
you're very precise young man and so
so the point is it's it you know it it
does this
and this
that's yours this does this
and this does the same thing except it's
hot it's got a little cool magnetic top
on the top
so so that's their purpose
they're good at it they become hard to
recognize
if they're harmed in a way that defeats
the purpose
the good and the being aristotle writes
are convertible terms
where you can use one in a sentence you
can use the other one good cup
being of the cup good book being of the
book
right good glasses being of the glasses
the basis of all human speech
is the common noun and every time we
identify one
we are identifying the good and the
being of a thing
horses love to run and they're beautiful
when they run
and so their ability to do that
that's what's awesome right if you uh
if you think that the word education
means lead forth
watch a horse go forward
and then watch it go backwards it's not
very good at that
well the point is if you can see that
about a horse
you can see it about a person
you see and then aristotle is going to
say
before we're done that if you practice
up through these
immediate and sometimes small
virtues every day in a way to build your
character
those people become good human beings
we're going to discover
face obstacles and the virtues
are the good confrontation
and tackling of those obstacles and
if you do that it will change you
and make you better you can become
awesome
start today
i'm larry iron president of hillsdale
college you will find if you look at our
online courses that they cover the whole
range of human learning
all the high and fundamental things
everyone needs to know
they are free because we have always
wished to provide
sound learning to anyone who wishes to
have it